Moscow correspondent Diana magnet joins
me now with the latest Dino is joining
us uh any minute now and Diana I think
we're gonna be able to hear your mic
uh in terms of what is the latest that
we've learned over the last couple of
hours
well we had a televised meeting between
General sullivikin who commands Russia's
operations in Ukraine and the defense
minister Sergey shoigu were essentially
sort of Eakin said
um we cannot Supply forces in Carson
anymore and to save the lives of Russian
servicemen we believe that we should
withdraw to the take up defensive
positions on the Eastern side of the
danipa river which is essentially the
other side of the Russian side of the
river essentially effectively leaving
her son to the ukrainians the ukrainians
had telegraphed that they would be
launching this kerasan counter-offensive
a couple of months ago before they even
retook that area around karkiv and it's
been a slow and steady grind but there
have been indications over the past week
or so that Russia Was preparing for some
kind of managed retreat they had for
example and this is one particularly
strange example but they'd removed the
body of potemke who was the lover of
Catherine the Second Catherine the Great
um and and taken him to the other side
of the danipa river and they'd blown up
a couple of a couple of bridges have
been blown up making it difficult to
supply Russian troops so I mean there
has been one comment from Kiev that uh
this may not necessarily be the case and
there have been suggestions in the
run-up to this possible withdrawal that
Russia could be preparing a trap but I
don't think that you see the head of the
Russian command in Ukraine in Ukraine
talk to the defense minister on live
television and say we're withdrawing to
the other side of the river and then for
it all to be a ruse because essentially
what you have now is that they have told
the Russian Nation this was televised
this was broadcast on state TV that they
are withdrawing from keson and Kirsten
was the only and the first the first and
the only Regional City that the Russians
took
um it was a long way from the original
uh plan well I mean whatever the
original plan was but Hassan is a long
way from Donetsk and luhansk which of
course were partially under uh
russian-backed control for a long time
and it was a massive overreach if now
Russia has decided to retreat so if we
look back on the last nine months Russia
pushed for Kiev at the beginning it had
to withdraw withdraw and managed
withdrawal it said at the time then we
saw the kharkiv counter-offensive where
a lot of territory was recaptured up
around kharkiv the loss of liman to
Russian to Ukrainian forces and now this
apparent Retreat from kerson I think
this is a very significant moment in the
war and interestingly one where Vladimir
Putin has effectively wiped his hands of
having to take political or military
ownership of this decision he was
touring a hospital today there's just
been new video of him meeting with a a
medical Head released by the Kremlin and
so I think he's very much said you know
we'll let the generals uh take the Flack
if you will and the justification for
this difficult decision as the defense
minister called it was to save the lives
of Russian servicemen but really a lot
of Russian servicemen have died taking
her son in the first place defending
herzon after that
um so I think this will raise a lot of
questions in Russia about why they had
to move so far if they now have to
retreat
um so it's a a significant moment it
does mean though that if Russia
withdraws to the Eastern side of the
danipa river they can consolidate their
positions as sorovicin said today he can
send soldiers to bolster other positions
along
um the front line so there might be
reasons why Russia would decide to do
that as winter approaches to consolidate
its descent defensive positions all the
way along that line nevertheless
Herson was the first and the only
Regional City they took and now they
have had to give it up and I I think
there will be a lot of rejoicing in
Ukraine and a lot of questions in Russia
as to how this special military
operation is going